>> SPECIAL COUNSEL JOHN DURHAM
DROPPING A BOMBSHELL THAT COULD
LEAD RIGHT BACK TO
HILLARY CLINTON.
THE COURT FILING ALLEGES
MULTIPLE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
STAFFERS HIRED A TECHNOLOGY TO
"INFILTRATE SERVERS AT
TRUMP TOWER" AND THEN LATER THE
ACTUAL WHITE HOUSE IN ORDER TO
TRY TO ESTABLISH A LINK FROM
DONALD TRUMP TO RUSSIA.
AND BREAKING THIS AFTERNOON,
SOURCES TONE FOX NEWS THAT THE
PROBE HAS ACCELERATED, WITH MORE
PEOPLE COOPERATING AND COMING
BEFORE A GRAND JURY.
REPUBLICANS SAY IT IS PROOF
THEY'VE BEEN RIGHT ALL ALONG AND
THAT HEADS SHOULD START ROLLING.
>> THIS IS WHAT IS SO EGREGIOUS
AND WRONG ABOUT IT.
THEY SPIED ON A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S AS WRONG AS IT GETS BUT
THEN WE FOUND OUT FROM THIS
FILING THAT THEY'VE SPIED ON THE
SITTING PRESIDENT, WHICH IS EVEN
WORSE.
>> I WOULD EXPECT THERE TO BE,
FRANKLY, QUITE A FEW MORE
INDICTMENTS.
I THINK THIS CONSPIRACY -- AND
THEY DO THINK THERE WAS A
CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY -- IS BROAD
AND DEEP.
>> AFTER ENDLESS COVERAGE OF THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION, THE MEDIA
SEEMS TO BE SILENT ON THIS
PARTICULAR DEVELOPMENT, AND AWAY
THEY COVERED THE DURHAM
INVESTIGATION IN THE PAST IS
DRAWING EVEN MORE SCRUTINY.
>> THE BIGGEST SCANDAL WAS WHEN
THEY SPIED ON MY CAMPAIGN.
>> THERE'S NO REAL EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
>> YES THERE IS.
IT'S ALL OVER THE PLACE.
THEY SPIED ON MY CAMPAIGN.
>> DONALD TRUMP AND WILLIAM BARR
PROMISE DURHAM WOULD EXPOSE HUGE
CORRUPTION, BUT HE HASN'T DONE
THAT.
>> APPARENTLY AN ONGOING
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN AND
PRO-TRUMP PROJECT TO TRY TO TURN
THE INVESTIGATION OF THE RUSSIA
SCANDAL INTO SOME KIND OF
SCANDAL ITSELF.
>> OH, NO, OKAY, WAIT UNTIL THE
DURHAM REPORT COMES OUT AND THEN
NOTHING HAPPENS AND THEY MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT CONSPIRACY THEORY.
>> I COULD JUST KEEP WATCHING
THAT MONTAGE BUT WE SHOULD TAKE
IT AROUND THE TABLE.
JUDGE, WHAT ABOUT THE DEVELOPER
THAT FOX NEWS IS REPORTING THAT
THERE IS ADDITIONAL COOPERATION
THAT'S HAPPENING WHICH IS WHY
THIS IS SPED UP A LITTLE BIT?
>> THAT MAKES SENSE IN A
SITUATION LIKE THIS.
I THINK EVERYONE WHO IS A
POTENTIAL DEFENDANT KNOWS WHO
THEY ARE IN THESE CASES AND THEY
ARE PROBABLY RECOGNIZING THAT
THEY'VE GOTTEN TO THE GUTS OF
THIS.
LOOK, THIS WAS AN ATTEMPT TO
FRAME A PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
TO FRAME HIM AS BEING A RUSSIAN
OPERATIVE, A PUTIN PUPPET AND IF
YOU RECALL, THE DAMAGE HERE IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
WE'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS AND AMERICA WAS TORN FOR
FOUR YEARS, WE WERE AT EACH
OTHER'S THROATS BECAUSE
HILLARY CLINTON, HER CAMPAIGN,
HIRED PEOPLE TO TRY TO MAKE A
CONNECTION BETWEEN A SERVER IN
THE TRUMP TOWER AND ONE IN A
RUSSIAN BANK THAT'S CONNECTED TO
PUTIN.
I MEAN, THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS, AND
THIS WOMAN WHO'S ALWAYS SMILING
AND, YOU KNOW, IS LIKE
DONALD TRUMP IS EVIL AND I AM
THE GREAT SALVATION, THE TRUTH
IS SHE'S BEEN THROUGH MORE
CRIMINAL -- QUASI CRIMINAL
ACTIVITIES FROM ERASING 33,000
EMAILS, MANY OF THEM CLASSIFIED,
SAID SHE NEVER HAD A CLASSIFIED
EMAIL ON HER LAPTOP OR HER
IPHONE WHEN SHE WAS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, AND SHE'S
GOT ALL OF THESE PROBLEMS AND
NOW THEY'RE GETTING TO THE GUTS
OF IT AND I THINK BY TRYING TO
FRAME THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, EVERY AMERICAN
SHOULD BE FURIOUS AND EVERY
POTENTIAL DEFENDANT OUT THERE
KNOWS THAT THEY'RE COMING FOR
YOU.
>> DOES THAT INCLUDE, I WOULD
ASSUME, HILLARY CLINTON, HAROLD,
WHO IS GOING TO BE ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS AT THE NEW YORK STATE
DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION AND
FLIRTED WITH THE IDEA OF RUNNING
AGAIN.
IT SEEMS TO LEAD RIGHT BACK UP
TO HER DOOR.
IN 2016 SHE PUT OUT A TWEET THAT
SAYS THERE NEEDS TO BE -- SEEMS
TO BE A CONNECTION HERE BUT IT
LOOKS LIKE THEY WERE FABRICATING
THAT CONNECTION THE FIRST PLACE
TO DRIVE NEWS COVERAGE.
>> IF THESE ALLEGATIONS BY
MR. DURHAM TURN OUT TO BE TRUE,
THE ONE THAT'S BEEN LEVELED
AGAINST THESE TWO LAWYERS OR
MAYBE A THIRD LAWYER, YOU HAVE
TO LET THE CHIPS FALL WHERE THEY
FALL.
I'M A RULE OF LAW PERSON, I
THINK THE CONSTITUTION, ALL OF
OUR RULE OF LAW DERIVES FROM
THAT.
I WOULD BE CAREFUL SO FAR TO
LINK HER TO THIS.
I'VE HEARD SOME PEOPLE CONFLATE
THE RHETORIC AND EQUATE BETWEEN
WATERGATE.
PRESIDENT NIXON APPROVED AND
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN THE
COVER-UP.
IS THAT IS PROVEN, JUDGE, OR IF
ANYONE AROUND THE TABLE, ANYBODY
WATCHING, MRS. CLINTON WILL HAVE
A LOT TO ANSWER FOR BUT BEFORE
WE GO THERE, MAKE THAT LEAP WITH
HER, I THINK WHAT WE HAVE ON THE
TABLE ALONE IS DISTURBING.
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING IT'S OBAMA
BEHIND THIS?
>> THE TWO OR THREE LAWYERS THAT
ESTHER DURHAM HAS LEVELED THESE
CHARGES WITH, THEY WENT OUT AND
PERHAPS HIRED SOMEONE TO
INFILTRATE THEN-CANDIDATE TRUMPS
SERVERS, THAT SHOULD DISTURB ANY
AMERICAN.
ANYBODY WHO BELIEVES IN THE RULE
OF LAW, ANYBODY WHO BELIEVES
POLITICS SHOULD BE LITIGATED ON
THE UP AND UP.
IF THAT IS PROVEN WITH THE CHIPS
FALL WHERE THEY MAY.
>> ONE OF THE REASONS THEY
FIGURED THIS OUT IS THAT LAWYERS
BUILD FOR THEIR TIME AND WHEN
YOU GO BACK TO THE BILLING
RECORDS YOU FIND OUT THAT THEY
WERE ALL BILLING IT TO THE
HILLARY CAMPAIGN.
>> AMAZING.
THIS IS WORSE THAN JANUARY 6,
9/11, WATERGATE, HINDENBURG
COMBINED.
THAT'S WHAT CNN WOULD SAY IF
THIS WERE TRUMP AND NOT HILLARY.
IN THIS CASE THEY ARE FOCUSING
INSTEAD ON JOE ROGAN, CLAIMING
THAT HIS USE OF THE N-WORD WAS
ANOTHER JANUARY 6TH.
THIS IS ANOTHER ILLUSTRATION OF
THE NEWS SPIGOT.
WITH -- THEY CAN TURN THAT
AWFUL, BLAST IT 24/7.
HUNTER LAPTOP, TURN IT OFF.
EVERYBODY'S LIKE WHAT HAPPENED,
WHERE TO GO.
BIDEN WINS AN ELECTION, YOU
DON'T HEAR ABOUT HUNTER.
TRUMP FLUSHES PAPERED ON THE
TOILET, AND THE SPIGOT COMES UP.
NOW YOU'VE GOT THIS COLLUSION,
REAL, AUTHENTIC RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, THIS IS ALL ABOUT
HILLARY, END OF SPIGOT GOES OFF.
AT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE SEE THIS EVERY DAY.
AND ALSO, THEY BLAME YOU FOR THE
THINGS THAT THEY DO, SO IT IS
LIKE, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE PUTTING
KIDS IN DANGER WHILE THEY DON'T
WEAR THE MASKS.
THEY ACCUSE YOU OF RACISM WHILE
SAYING THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
TOXICITY OF WHITENESS IS
EVERYWHERE AND IN HIS CASE
CREATED A HOAX BEHIND A
DIFFERENT HOAX.
>> IN ORDER TO DRIVE NEWS
COVERAGE THAT EVERYBODY WOULD
FOLLOW.
MARK ELIAS IS THIS ATTORNEY THAT
EVERYBODY SHOULD PAY ATTENTION
TO.
DEMOCRAT.
DEMOCRATS ARE EVEN MAD AT HIM
FOR SCREWING UP THE ARIZONA CASE
BUT WHEN YOU ARE COOPERATION, IT
SORT OF MEANS TO ME THAT PEOPLE
JUST DON'T WANT TO GO TO JAIL SO
THEY START TALKING.
>> I THINK HILLARY SHOULD BE
BANISHED FROM POLITE SOCIETY.
OUR NOT COMPARING HER TO O.J.
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE NO
PROOF THAT SHE EVER MURDERED
ANYBODY, BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
HILLARY TREATED THE WAY O.J. IS.
HE'S NOT REALLY WELCOME PLACES,
HE'S KIND OF A PARIAH.
RIGHT NOW SHE IS A CERTIFIED
POLITICAL CRIMINAL.
IF HER HUSBAND HAS BEEN
#METOOED AND HAS BEEN FINGER TO
BE ON EPSTEIN'S ISLAND AND YOU
KNOW THE FOUNDATION, THAT'S JUST
A WASHED UP MONEY LAUNDERING
OPERATION.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED.
SHE PAID PEOPLE TO HACK INTO
TRUMP'S COMPUTERS AND FRAME HIM
FOR BEING A RUSSIAN TRADER!
THAT WOULD BE LIKE PAYING
SOMEONE TO BREAK INTO
TRUMP TOWER AT 2:00 IN THE
MORNING, PLANT A BUNCH OF DRUGS
AND GUNS AND RUSSIAN DOCUMENTS
AND THEN CALL THE FBI AND SAY
HEY GUYS, IS GOT A TIP, WHY
DON'T YOU GO RAID THE TOWER.
THAT'S THE SAME THING.
AND WE NOW KNOW TOO THAT THIS
WAS HAPPENING AS FAR BACK AS
2014.
THE CIA KNEW CROOKED WAS TRYING
TO FRAME HIM, THEY BRIEFED OBAMA
THAT HILLARY WAS GOING TO FRAME.
THEY BRIEFED THE FBI THAT THIS
WAS A FRAME JOB SO
ROBERT MUELLER WAS JUST A -- AND
IT FAILED.
IT'S NOT -- I THINK GREG WAS
BEING FACETIOUS I THINK BUT WHEN
YOU LOOK ABOUT JANUARY 6TH AND
THEN YOU LOOK AT THIS, WHAT DID
MORE DAMAGE?
I MEAN, THINK ABOUT HOW MANY
PEOPLE'S LIVES WERE DESTROYED,
HOW WE DIVIDED THE COUNTRY, HOW
IT MADE US QUESTION OUR
DEMOCRACY, QUESTION OUR ELECTION
AND OUR INSTITUTIONS.
IT RUINED MULTIPLE THANKSGIVINGS
FOR ME PERSONALLY.
I THINK WE NEED TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
AS THEY SAY, BIG IS TRUE.
>> YOU KNOW WHO WORKED ON THE
WATERGATE COMMITTEE, REMEMBER?
HILLARY HERSELF.
>> THAT'S RIGHT!
FULL-CIRCLE, AS THEY SAY.
>> IT A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT